[Music]
you all came highly
recommended you know the rules no real
names no Back
stories no s so whose kid is she a very
wealthy man who's about to be $50
million
poorer I'm here to make sure you're safe
what's your name mine's Abigail you can
call me Joey do you have any
kids I have a little boy see you in
[Music]
hours do you know what a pinky promises
if you behave and do as we
say like pinky promise you it'll all be
over
soon Joey
yeah I'm sorry about what's going to
happen to
you what the
[__] [__] we got to get out of
here I think she knows
something
guys
guys oh
no what the [__] is that thing we
kidnapped a [__]
[Music]
vampire a ballerina
vampire okay how do we kill a vampire
what are we talking about like an an
rice or a True Blood you know Twilight
State through the heart daylight is a
big
one all right let's go kill us a [__]
vampire
ready
rire on my
[Music]
[Applause]
ass what can I say I like playing with
my
food whoa whoa whoa she's [__]
[Music]
flying
I [__] hate
ballet